Round 9.564, or nine and
five hundred sixty-four
thousandths, to the
nearest tenth.
So let me write it a little
bit larger, 9.564.
And we need to round to
the nearest tenth.
So what's the tenth place?
The tenths plays
is right here.
This right here represents
5 tenths.
This is the ones place, this is
the tenths place, this is
the hundredths place,
and this is the
thousandths place right here.
So we need to round to
the nearest tenth.
So if we round up,
this will be 9.6.
If we round down, this
will be 9.5.
And just like regular rounding,
when we're not
dealing with decimals, you move
to one spot, or you look
at one place to the right or one
place lower, I guess, and
you say is that 5 or larger?
If it is, you round up, if
it isn't, you round down.
6 is definitely 5 or larger,
so we want to round up.
So this 9.564 becomes 9.6,
or we can call this
nine and six tenths.
And then we're done!